This week, Japanese game publisher Bandai Namco...
...is opening its new VR Zone here in Shinjuku, Tokyo.
Unlike its previous six-month temporary site in Odaiba,...
...VR Zone Shinjuku will operate for two years...
...and is expected to serve five to seven times as many people daily.
Ahead of the official launch on Friday,...
...I got to preview some of the 12 VR games there.
Most notably, there's Mario Kart VR, which is a multiplayer game...
...linking up to a maximum of four rides...
...and you get to play as either Mario, Luigi, Peach or Yoshi.
It's very much like the classic game, but strictly in first person view...
...and you do have to reach out to grab and throw your weapon.
It can be either a banana, a shell or a hammer.
This was easily my favorite game and I'm sure many people will feel the same way.
Oh yeah!
Another highly anticipated game though is Dragon Ball VR...
...in which you get to learn how to make your own Kamehameha...
...so that you can fight the person in the other booth.
I was greeted by Goku, who gave me step-by-step instructions,...
...and after destroying a few large rocks,...
...I was teleported to the battlefield to face my enemy.
I loved how the platform and the gloves vibrated while I was generating Kamehameha...
...and as a bonus, the platform also blew a breeze in front of me.
Hopefully, we'll get to go Super Saiyan in the future release of this game.